all right let's do a little what's more
likely super wild card weekend edition
baby first game super wild cards on
saturday
you haven't made fun of that this week
or anything i'm surprised
that seems to be like that would be in
your wheelhouse to make fun of that
okay fine no comment let's move on
coltsen bills to start
philip rivers has no interceptions or
josh allen has
three or more total touchdowns what's
more likely oh
well i you know this this one's one of
the more easier ones that pete dembele
little lettuce has ever put in here
i'm definitely going with josh allen
three plus total tds
i mean i would never bet and anything to
say phillip rivers is going to throw
zero interceptions especially a playoff
game where things are going to be tight
so no allen is on fire i could easily
see him have two touchdowns throwing two
running whatever combination you want to
get and yeah i don't totally trust
philip rivers that way so i'm going with
allen three plus total tds
i'm still intrigued and we'll be talking
about this and we'll be making our
official selections later today for the
joint mega pix podcast pftpm and chris
sims unbuttoned
will the colts be able to crack some
sort of a code keep josh allen on the
sideline drinking
i hear you use jonathan taylor to slow
the game down take the full
40 seconds phillip rivers savvy veteran
safe throws
not taking any chances not making that
stupid mistake in what could be
his last career game right a lot of
potential
last career games coming up this weekend
whether it's ben rothsberger phillip
rivers drew brees or andrew whitworth
but i still think josh allen will will
do josh allen things with 6 700 fans
present it's his opportunity to connect
with buffalo fans for the first time
this year
in a game setting at home
it's all been pointing to this and
remember last year
when we talked about the bills
unleashing josh
allen as a runner in the playoffs and
they
did i'm still eating bits of that acorn
that the blind squirrel found last year
expect it again josh allen
unleashed you don't have to do it this
year because as a passer he's a hell of
a lot more potent
yeah right but if the opportunity is
there to take off he's going to take off
because he's big and he's fast and he's
strong and you don't want to get in his
way no no no doubt about it it's
it's an you know a joker card they got
there with his ability to do that stuff
they will run lamar jackson type of game
plan runs every now and then and you're
right in every big game
and especially last year early in the
playoffs where you were 100
right you called it they used them in a
lot of different ways remember you had a
huge long run down the right sideline
they had the quarterback throwback trick
play where he caught a pass for a
touchdown
so and we've seen buffalo this year
really become second to new england and
the team that'll run the most trick
plays in the game
they're not afraid to do it they don't
give a damn if they're hey we're
executing great we've got another play
you got to worry about here you go
trick play you're screwed so uh that's
why they're fun to watch and
and your aspect about the colts and
their ability to run the ball lately
behind that o-line and that running back
i think is a very fair question very
good question mike i i'm
going to be interested to see maybe if
they take that approach
another angle to keep an eye on there's
an increasing sense that brian dabal the
buffalo offensive coordinator is going
to get the job in houston and that could
make this bill's team
feel even more compelled to finish the
job the right way
next year things could be very different
offensively
let's see it through to the end because
day ball
is likely going to be rewarded not
likely i don't know what the word
properly is quite possibly will be
rewarded seems that way he's done this
year by becoming the head coach of the
houston texans
rams at seahawks what's more likely
russell wilson has two or more
passing touchdowns or two or more
interceptions chris
wow i mean you know
i i don't see him having some huge
day of like two three four touchdown
passes not against this rams defense
but i'm gonna go with the two plus
passing touchdowns if i have to pick
either one
russell wilson really ever since that
first rams game where they lost 23 to 16
in la and they lost the game because he
threw two interceptions and i believe
fumbled once too
he has been ultra ultra
conservative with the football ever
since then to a point mike where
you know he was he's he was scarred by
that game is what i'm saying
even like when i watch back ram seahawks
week 16
there was a few plays and throws in the
game where i go cut it loose
throw it he's open like throw it but i
think he was going he just didn't quite
like it
and if he's not a hundred percent sure
then he's gonna take the conservative
approach
that's what he's gonna do right now i
think he realizes the way the defense is
playing and all that so
i'm gonna go with the two plus past tds
yeah it's a tough one i'm going to agree
i'm going to agree with you but by aaron
between aaron donald and jalen randy
i know what jayla ramsay's been able to
do to dk metcalf
i'll reluctantly agree but i i
i don't feel real good about it because
i think it could be more likely that he
throws a couple of interceptions
even if he throws them early and then
later overcomes it right we which we've
seen him do in the playoffs in the past
buccaneers at washington saturday night
what's more likely
tom brady has three or more passing
touchdowns or
chase young has two or more sacks oh
this is one where i look at him both
could happen very
easily that's for sure i'm gonna go with
brady in the three points
chase young chase young doesn't have a
multiple sack game all year though
that's that's a you know kind of
interesting you know you don't
i don't picture it that way because you
know again that's where stats are a
little different because it's just
he he's f he f's the play up a whole lot
and damn when you watch a game you just
go gosh is he is he living and camping
next to the quarterback
so that that is an amazing stat uh but i
still even with that i'm going to go
with brady of the three plus pass tds
i i just they have such a big powerful
offensive line they pass protect really
well they go out of their way to keep
extra guys in like we've talked about a
lot mike where they'll keep
six men in to block four guys they don't
care so now brady feels comfortable and
he's gonna dice you up and the way he's
throwing on that offense is going
i'm going with brady the back and forth
between chase young and tom brady as
fast
it is cool chase young tried to back off
yesterday and tom brady
he's a great young player look tom
brady's not going to say anything
until it's time to get on the field and
then he's going to say everything and if
he throws a touchdown pass or if he
eludes chase young to emerge and throw a
key first down
you're going to see tom brady letting
chase young hear about it because we
know that's how tom brady is chase young
by the way both the nfc
defensive player of the month and the
nfl's defensive
rookie of the month and it's just a
matter of time before he's the nfl's
defensive rookie
of the year so congratulations to him i
love his attitude
yeah what i just love his attitude i
like that yeah he's a little bit more
vocal in your face
hey defensive players you're not here to
make friends and give
you know offensive players you know
bouquets of flowers and things
intimidation and all that is part of the
game and that's where
you know i i like that aspect of him
where he kind of welcomes it all sorry
sorry to interrupt you
i really enjoyed sitting with him and
talking to him at the scouting combine
back before the world turned upside down
were you while you were
unavailable because yeah yeah
thank you thank you we need to have that
video of you making the
the exit with the trash can uh we had
need to have that on speed dial to roll
in whenever this comes up but
he just gets it he gets it you know some
of these guys aren't mature he's got
that maturity he's got that wisdom he's
got that business sense he gets it
he has confidence ultimately in his
abilities and
you know look i don't know that there's
enough around him to make a difference
against tampa bay
but this is a great great development
for a washington franchise that
will have chase young creating havoc
like this for years to come
ravens titans that is the first game on
sunday what's more likely baltimore has
200 or more rushing yards or derrick
henry has
150 or more rushing yards on his own wow
man that is that's another good one man
pizza on fire today these are tough ones
i
i'm gonna go with baltimore has 200 plus
rushing yards
if i have to pick one of the other i am
you know
first time they played i know derek
henry had 133 yards
you know you know it came in like it
wasn't like a consistent
crushing it was a little bit like man
run for nothing run for nothing run for
nothing
rip off a run for 15. and then we had
the 30-yard run in overtime right and
all those things
let's not forget they had they bought
the more ravens had no kaleas campbell
and no brandon williams in that football
game either
and i just got to think the ravens got
to go all out to stop that aspect or
they have no chance because if he starts
running
then it's going to be aj brown and corey
davis play action passes
bombs away all of that so i'm gonna take
baltimore with the 200 plus rushing
yards even though i don't feel
necessarily
crazy good about that either baltimore's
had 200 more rushing yards in for their
last five games they
had only 129 against tennessee in that
week 11 loss
last year in the playoffs derek henry
had 195 against the ravens and
and and he didn't do the stiff arm to
earl thomas earl thomas didn't give him
the chance
to do so earl thomas turned and ran away
from derek henry or he would have been
top 10
of uh yes and available to anyone who
needs to sign him for the playoffs he's
available
if you haven't heard he's been available
all year top 10 safety in football
still available to be signed by anyone
who's looking for help it's amazing that
none of these playoff teams
have pounced on a top 10 safety in
football next up
bears what's more likely khalil mack has
two or more sacks of drew brees or drew
brees has three or more passing
touchdowns chris
wow drew brees having three or more
touched you know passing touchdowns i i
think
you know i could see them slowly carving
up
this chicago defense it's going to be
interesting you know i i do think it's
you know the start of the game could be
something here with with
chuck pagano sean payton to see just
does he have a good feel
is it going to be one of those days
where you know like we saw the rams and
the vikings do
we knew in those games against the
saints early on we were like whoa
they're making life hard on this doesn't
look like the same old saints
and i think we always kind of have a
feel sometimes with them like pretty
early where you can go oh this is one of
the days where it's going to be tough
and then sometimes you see days where
you just go oh
they got it they you know peyton's
cracked the code drew feels good
everything's good all there but i'm
going to go with drew definitely khalil
mack
still really awesome football player but
not as dominant
a little bit more underwhelming than you
know i would like
as the superstar player he's supposed to
be
back in week eight when the bears and
the saints played in chicago brees had
two touchdowns and mack had one sack of
breeze
the last game of the weekend browns at
steelers nbc and peacock
what's more likely baker mayfield has
two touchdowns slash no interceptions
or ben roethlisberger has two touchdowns
slash no interception well i'll go with
big ben i mean we know they're going to
throw the football
you know it's not a great defense for
the cleveland browns
the the steelers can't run it in from
inside the five-yard line so that's
gonna lead to touchdown passes and all
that and of course yes
it is the pittsburgh defense and all
they do and they create turnovers and
interceptions so
if i'm picking one i'm gonna go with ben
roethlisberger has two tds no
interceptions
uh i you know i agree with you i just i
feel like this is such a tough spot for
cleveland and yes could they
could they rise past all of this
adversity they could
they could you can't rule it out they've
been through so much
you know this is gravy for them they
should have no pressure on them
whatsoever going into this game but
i think ben roethlisberger yet another
guy that sees his career possibly ending
if they would lose i think he's going to
rise above that one more from
the brown steelers game defensive side
of the ball
what's more likely miles garrett has two
or more sacks for the browns
or tj watt has two or more sacks for the
steelers oh
that is a good one i'm gonna go with
miles garrett
i am um just because i think tj watts
got to worry about the
run game and everything like that you
know there's a lot more to worry about
on that side of the ball he does drop
into coverage sometimes
where miles gary just gets to rush the
passer all the time and just like we
just said
you know pittsburgh is going to drop
back 40 something times to throw the
football
and so i would think he gets you know a
chance at a handful there just
can he get the sack so if i'll pick
there i'll go miles garrett
yeah you know what i agree with you as
well especially because there's gonna be
so much
urgency on that defense to to
step up you don't have kevin stefanski
there to call plays offensively there's
gonna be a greater urgency for the
defense to make a difference to keep the
browns in the game let me ask you one
question if you don't mind like
what's more likely who come who is more
likely to come back
next year out of rivers breeze and big
ben
how do you kind of put that pecking
order there together if you if you had a
rank it
i'd say ben
is most likely to come back rivers two
breeze three
okay what do you think yeah i i i i
agree with you with ben
and then the other ones where i'm a
little flipped there i i because i guess
a little bit is depending on how these
guys do
i don't know i feel like there's somehow
that drew brees is going to want to come
back
and uh i'm going to play drew to rivers
3. that would be how i look at it but
very close there
but if the saints don't want drew brees
i know if he hasn't already gotten that
message maybe they'll make it more
obvious to him later
he's not going to go play for someone
else i know rivers
here's the question and and i didn't
think he would find someone who was
willing to immediately
install him as the starter after the
performance we saw last year with the
chargers
frankly he has to find someone who is
willing to say
you're the guy here's another 25 million
or 23 million or whatever million based
upon the reduction in the salary cap due
to the pandemic
here it is for you to continue playing
football and the other side of it is
will there be a network out there that
is throwing
half that amount 60 of that amount who
knows
at phillip rivers to come be their
next top analyst there's already been
some reporting that networks are
watching phillip rivers and i think he
would be great
he'd be great the the his his mannerisms
how did he do that so you know i mean he
would be great you're right
it's almost like if you can't get peyton
manning
you get philip rivers and i'm telling
you there's a way with philip rivers
that it could fall
that he could be better than any of them
he yeah we're all where's the next john
madden
in a weird sort of way with dad gummits
and the gosh darns
and his passion for the game yeah and i
think he will communicate
very well to cause the best thing about
john madden i know we're going to take a
break the best thing about john madden
was
he didn't communicate about the game in
a way that alienated the casual fan
doesn't understand the secret the code
of football guys right
too many people get in the booth and
they want to impress people by showing
that they know the secret code of
football guys the double a gap and
crossing the face and all of that crap
right that alienates
the casual fan philip rivers would never
do that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports